um urine therapy urine yes urine the
bodily fluid urine uh christopher keys
who is another one of these covid
conspiracists he's an anti-vaxx leader
of sorts
he is now urging followers to drink
their own urine to fight covid
uh let's take a look at the clip
this is quite vile and also incredibly
stupid take a look at this
the antidote that we've seen now and we
have tons and tons of research
is
urine therapy that's right folks you are
not don't adjust your television he is
saying urine you are ine
okay
and i know to a lot of you
a lot of you this sounds crazy right but
guys god's given us everything we need
okay
and i'm gonna give you again
i test and prove all things okay
um
this has been around for centuries um
we've got research after research
documented peer-reviewed published
papers on your end now it is true that
there are
peer-reviewed published papers about
urine
it's not about urine curing kovid now
understand that there's a backstory to
this there's a backstory to all of these
ideas there's a like a recycling of old
ideas going on urine has been promoted
in the past for treating cancer cancer
society says there's no evidence of
therapeutic use of urine
people talk about irrigating your
sinuses with a neti pot some people use
distilled filtered water for the neti
pot there's the idea of using urine
running urine through your sinuses
brushing your teeth with urine that's an
interesting one
applying urine directly to the skin for
some kind of skin treatment
the source of all of this is a simple
idea that there are certain tumor
proteins present in the urine of cancer
patients and the idea came from if you
introduce urine
into the body in different ways then the
body will start to make antibodies
against the tumor proteins and it might
destroy the cancer or have other
benefits it's all bogus it's true that
urine can contain tumor antigens there's
no evidence that shows that drinking it
using it for massages using it to bake a
cake bathing in it or any other urine
applications actually does any of the
things that it's claimed to do now i
want to be thorough here when we talk
about urine we need to be thorough
there is one possible
bridge use of urine
for health purposes okay now does
anybody know what it is
if you are completely dehydrated and
without water and you're on the verge of
dying
urine is 95 water
there is some belief that for the very
short term you might be able to survive
in a at a point of catastrophic
dehydration
by drinking your urine for a day or
maybe two okay
urine ins in a general sense it's 95
water it's safe to drink it will
replenish some lost water
the problem is that that other five
percent that's not water
isn't stuff you want a lot of in your
body you're basically taking the stuff
your kidneys have filtered out and
you're putting it back in and it'll end
up back in your kidneys and you can end
up with really really bad symptoms from
long-term drinking of urine but if
you're in a completely desperate
situation no water
you're close to death
it's conceivable that drinking your own
urine might let you survive just a
little bit until you get rescued or
whatever there's actually uh the book
437 days about the
fisherman salvador alvarenga who drifted
offshore mexico ended up in the pacific
islands at some brief periods he drank
his own urine but he very quickly
figured out how to collect rain water he
would not have been able to survive
just drinking urine for 437 days so
that's the truth about so-called urine
therapy christopher key's dangerous
conspiracist not to be followed
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video